my name is Kristen so I'm at irrational
labs right now an irrational labs how
many of you know Dan Ariely great so he
is a kind of famed author professor at
Duke and kind of a thought leader he is
a thought leader in behavioral economics
so what a rational Labs does is try to
merge this this understanding of human
behavior human psychology and then teach
products that are trying to change the
world how to better improve their users
lives through understanding the
psychology of their users so relates to
trying to take the academic world and
say hey product folks there's those
learnings over here that you guys should
be paying attention to while you try to
go and build products that will change
people's lives forever so how we do that
I'm current we kind of is we don't like
to say consulting but it's we help we
help companies do this
we're helping Google we've helped Intuit
netflix fidelity lyft and basically they
come to us with all sorts of problems
from trying to increase willingness to
pay to helping people save money to
helping people save time employee
motivation kind of you name it and you
think about the the stuff that's in the
academic world of understanding human
behavior and it could be applied to help
them solve their problems we also do
events so every year we'll have startups
and academics get in a room and hang out
for about three days and and basically
share insights and they walk away with
experiment designs and the academics
learn what folks in the real world are
doing and the product people actually
have had a theory that came shortcut a
little bit of their roadmaps and then
most recently and I'm very excited about
this on Monday we're releasing workbooks
so we basically took the last year and a
half and said very nice and you can
definitely read Daniel Kahneman's
Thinking Fast and Slow dan Ariely books
but in general there's still this kind
of missing link between how we talk
about the learnings and of human
behavior and product folks and so these
workbooks are our effort owes about 10
of them and they go through key
behaviors and incentives and pricings
and social proof to try to connect the
gap and is literally we want people to
print this out I know this is crazy I
don't even know what I'm thinking but
the thinking is that you would sit in a
room with your product team and think
about how do you how do you enter
meaning the users life to help them help
bridge this intention and action gap and
trying to give folks the tools to do
that versus just talking to three or
five users which is very nice very
insightful but we think there's probably
a better way and that's kind of what I'm
gonna talk today about is there's a
better way so it's a product community
you know we can we're trying to change
people's lives and and I think that we
could be doing it in a in a more
successful way so the one way we could
we could do this I just remember looking
at the product and basically say what a
principle is a product development that
would help us to design better products
but what I'd propose because behavioral
economics is really about the study of
how people make decisions that we take
more lessons from life so I'm going to
share some lessons from my life and then
we'll apply it and figure out how to
scale that out into principles of
product product and behavioral design
thinking so obviously every good story
starts with the womb and so I'm a twin
that's me this is my sister and we're
fraternal twins and so if you don't know
about fraternal twins what happens is it
about ninety-nine point nine five
percent of our DNA is the same just like
sisters but the thing about fraternal
twins is that we share basically
everything right so we shared bunk beds
obviously parents lunches clothes
classes sports transportation to and
from school like everything right
actually so the funny thing I told my
sister this like little spiel is showed
those slide last night and so this is
what I was saying she's like you know
Brittany we shared everything and she
looked through she's like Kristen we
shared everything except boyfriend's
like this is very on point comment and
then we look to each other said actually
one and it was like wow that's like I'll
share that with the class tomorrow and
so even if you think about this and how
similar we are this is what we look like
now this is my sister she is a yogi
meditative like somebody who's like
India pure San Francisco like this girl
will like she just represents the
culture of Yogi's in San Francisco and
I'm this professional multitasker I
leave during stretching exercises yeah
you know at the end of workouts like I
can be doing you know three things but
if I'm doing one this is terrible
and you think about how actually we
became so different and in reality it's
that this is kind of the first lesson
here we have small details make a big
difference or so the very small details
obvious in our DNA and in an environment
make a huge difference on the outcomes
of our life I'll go on to the next one
so other big decisions and maybe this
has hit you guys before coming to
Stanford or I'll hit you after but in at
some point you have to make a decision
about where you want to live and so at
your school I had a job offer from a
nice consulting company in Chicago or I
was gonna go to Intuit and hang out in
San Francisco and so the obvious thing
you look at how much they're gonna pay
you and Intuit pay me nine thousand
dollars more and is any college kid I
was like this is a very good deal nine
thousand dollars more in San Francisco
fabulous and then you think well this is
a terrible way to think about the world
say San Francisco is actually much more
expensive as I soon found out when I got
here I looked this up and it's a hundred
percent more for bread Rice's and then
78 percent more for rent and so but what
I did is something called this money
illusion so you take X and you take X
plus nine and then you'd say which is
better now you have something that's
butter it's a very easy to do equation
but the reality is that's not what I
should have done despite the cost of
living you think about what I should
have paid attention to and you know the
commutes I'm living in San Francisco
going to going to Mountain View's
commute is not not one of the things
that increases our happiness by any
means.the culture so you have all these
texts folks in San Francisco you've got
kind of like the Midwest corn like
playing dodgeball after work folks in
Chicago and then the other thing is
obviously this kind of concept the
mating possibilities this is what you
should look at if you're making a long
term decision that he'll have you know
impact and you know there were more men
in San Francisco less in Chicago but
then again as I was doing this research
I rose they include engineers I no just
kidding guys totally kidding seeing how
that would go
okay so the point of it though you're
moving across cities huge decision huge
life decision and you're paying
attention to what you're paying
attention to incorrect math and only one
factor but it's the most salient factor
and so I'm actually it was you know
using my gut intuition on this on this
you know in theory one of the biggest
decisions that I'll make in my life or
one the thing that will determine
outcomes the most okay so the the next
kind of life life epiphany only happened
about six months ago and so six months
ago I started using stitch fix do we
know stitch fix trunk club for men okay
so these are services that ship you
clothes you try them on and if you don't
like them you ship them back kind of
kind of crazy right so it's like a
Zappos but instead of you actually going
and ordering they literally just ship
you a ton of clothes that's six items I
don't know trunk Club does ship you
items that you ship them back before
stitch fix I didn't get any compliments
on my clothes nothing and I realized the
reason I signed up for stitches is my
roommate I've got a new roommate and
she's very very stylish she's like a
person for females like it's like her
she has told Paula she's nail polish on
her toes that matches like her bag like
this is the extent of how cell it's just
woman is I was reeling why don't I do
this and it's like it's not that I don't
want to be stylish like that looks very
nice right like who wouldn't want to
look very nice this is this is great
what I realize is that is actually a lot
of work being such is a lot of work and
so it's not that I didn't want to be
such is actually there's a ton of
friction involved with me being stop me
wanting to be stylish and me actually
being stylist and so stitch fix comes
along ships me clothes I have them I try
them on and now like literally before
six months ago I was wearing black and
this is the only time that I would get
compliments and now I'm actually no I'm
now pointing to my outfit so you have to
hope hopefully it passes the bar of just
being better than all black but in
reality it also makes the decision
harder and if you think about that
decision in no way could stitch fix be
better at deciding what I would like
then I am right I've answered a five
question questionnaire how could I
possibly like the stuff that citric
sends me more than me to investing and
like look
for clothes that would actually fit and
look nice on me in reality it's a lot of
work to be to have to go shopping versus
actually have them shipped back to you
so so here's kind of this somebody like
the environment around me I've moved in
with my roommate I realize holy
there's other there's another world out
there of style that I could be in right
right isn't that what we all think I
avoided I avoided friction it takes a
lot of time and then the concept of
actually just having to give stuff up
made me made me follow through with it
right because I have to ship something
back and I'd already tried it on okay so
so what I'd like to pause it here is
basically that the fabric of human
decision-making is not necessarily big
principles but it's what we the mistakes
the mistakes we make in our day-to-day
life right so that so how how humans
behave is not this abstract concept but
it's how we make decisions and how we
fail to make good decisions and and how
this could impact our future and our
outcomes and so kind of as a you know
someone positing this you say well is
this actually true where's your proof
and so now we'll kind of go through what
the academics have said about what these
life lessons are and the fabric of our
decisions and figure out how we can
apply that to the the product world okay
so this is any vegetarians in the
audience okay so this is you won't like
any of these but when they survey people
about which one they like more it turns
out without the label equal you start
calling something seventy five percent
lean twenty five percent fat and all of
a sudden the world changes and people
are very very negative about the 25% fat
label now in reality nothing has changed
right these burgers are the exact same
piece of meat and yet we kind of change
our whole whole frame on than just by
the small details of all the things that
I think that the behavioral economics
world has given folks this is paying
attention to the small details and how
will change big outcomes in big behavior
okay so this is
we incorrectly pay attention to what's
easily measurable I've got an intuition
it's not I was right okay so at some
point in your life I don't know I gave a
talk and asked people how many people
have bought houses and everyone raised
their hands I'm guessing in this room
has anyone bought a house with one house
buyer two husband three awesome so other
people can imagine a world a world where
you have to buy a house I know it's not
gonna happen in San Francisco for many
of us and anytime soon it's a small
house big house these are kind of
decision you have to understand what are
your preferences in in buying a house
anyone have an idea of what would go
into making up someone's preferences of
purchasing a house this is one of the
biggest decisions people will make any
time great family size okay yeah
location yep right size yeah cleaning
schools cleaning so the size basically
yeah
preference for cleaning how much you
like it or you don't like it we've kind
of also thought of other ones preference
for luxury so how much you actually like
you know the status symbol taxes could
be another one depending on what state
you're from so every seaman sent did a
nice study and basically said well let's
actually look at this scientifically and
he took people who are moving from San
Francisco and Alabama and said we're
gonna go to Pittsburgh and what would
determine what house people would buy if
they're moving from different cities and
what he did was basically take people
with the same exact income right so
money was not a question they had the
same exact means to purchase houses and
so what now was the kind of what how did
people decided they're gonna buy a
bigger small house Oh yep exactly so in
in a perfectly rational world the prices
of the city that you're moving to would
be what we should look at not the prices
of the city that you're moving from
right this is a little crazy but if
you're moving from an expensive city
you'd buy an expensive house doesn't
matter the prices doesn't matter you
know how the house actually looks so
your preference for luxury or your
family size or any of these other
factors that were
controlled for it matters actually the
where you moved from so this is
interesting right because this is that
one of the biggest decisions that we're
gonna make you know from our wealth
perspective and giving up money in our
in our lifetime and yet we're using it
on a heuristic that just doesn't make
sense and you could tell because after
year these people either downgraded if
that a big house are they upgrade if at
a small house so their preferences upon
moving weren't reflective of their
overall preferences and those were were
soon determined after about a year
living with this this one decision ok
the last little piece of this is that
the it's the environment around us that
matters friction is terrible and that we
hate to give things up that we have and
so this is in the base in the 1980s in
the savings world for companies when
they were trying to offer their
employees a retirement plan it was
called the Field of Dreams approach and
what this meant was that they were gonna
just throw out all of the savings and
options that you could at someone so you
get to trick which asset class you want
you get to pick how much you get to save
all these variables were open to people
to decide and what happened is that
researchers and this was a good thing
right you give people more choice if you
just if you give them offers they will
save if you give them options they will
save and this was kind of the resounding
factor and what happened is that a lot
of researchers that this is very
interesting but probably not correct and
so they said you know if we just give
people the option to save how many
people save and then if we give people
the option to say but we ottoman we are
we give them the kind of automatic
enrollment checkbox and in one case we
give them an automatic enrollment with
three percent in one case with six
percent in one case they don't have the
automatic enrollment now when you have
the automatic enrollment more people
save but the interesting thing with this
study is that when you give people
automatic enrollment or three or six
percent both the same number of people
save so again it's not that you have a
preference kind of like the clothing is
that that you have a preference not to
save is that there's too much friction
in between you doing something and
you're not doing something and so by
closing the gap of friction you're able
to meet the attention and
action gap that's exactly what happened
here because you know if you say I have
a preference to save or not save then
these should be different because you
actually have a preference that is three
three to six percent and the amount that
you would save okay so so I kind of said
this is a joke my lessons you know
behavior equal behavioral economics
principles but in reality we're thinking
about the the aggregate like fabric of
human decision-making and trying to
apply that to the principles of
behavioral economics so when I say
behavioral economics and I've been
saying this a lot I just want to pause
to give a definition does anyone have a
definition that they'd like to share
with us behavioral economics is I once
did something Simon it story I get a
friend mad at you they post something on
Facebook and then no one responds and
you do a 12-minute soundtrack of
crickets which is very funny so so the
the long-form explanation that I usually
say is typical economics is a supply and
demand curve and this is very nice in
theory but a lot of times it doesn't
work there are other factors acting on
us that will deviate us from a pure
supply and demand so whether it be that
other people are around or that the
words on a label are different you know
or that you think you're going to lose
something at some point we're a deviate
from the perfect supply and demand world
and behavioral economics seeks to
understand why we do that how we do it
and then the behavioral academics seek
to graph that and if you call it social
science they don't care as much about
graphing but they still care about
deviating from the norm of rational
behavior cool so we're on the same page
as we go on okay so so then the question
is okay great we've got Gregerson we've
got all of these principles of human
behavior that applied to kind of
aggregate fabric of decision making
we are in the product world and we want
to know how to apply this stuff to our
day-to-day life and so over the past
day-to-day life is in building and
thinking about building products for
other people so for the past year and a
half we've we've kind of outlined the
process that we take when we're thinking
about taking an academic science and
applying it to the product world and I'm
going to I'm going to use a term that is
that is a little bit overdone in the
valley here if I go to Kansas it'll be
wildly received but hacking as a
metaphor and so the concept of hacking
really is that and this actually quote
sums it up a hacker can find a tiny
vulnerability to get into a server and
then remove they'll remove this and so
what this is is it hackers have a deep
curiosity they look at the full system
and then they attack the small details
and that's basically how we think about
applying behavioral economics to product
questions is that we have a deep
curiosity for why someone's doing
something their mindset we're looking at
the whole system of how they're making
that decision and we're finding that
tiny vulnerability to understand how we
can bridge the intention and action gap
okay so I just want to give us like a
tangible example of like why hacker is
cool and if you know the target example
you know that basically they hacked in
to the system in in two ways so hackers
had to figure out how to hack into the
credit card system and then they fit had
to figure out how to store it and the
theory behind this and I'm not an expert
in security either I've tried to talk to
security experts to validate this they
give me the head now that generically
this is correct that they basically
there's a tiny instant before the credit
card is it is is saved into is encrypted
from when it's taken to it's encrypted
that it's stored in this Ram store and
at that second they can pull this
because there's a vulnerability but the
people still have to get into the system
and still have to store it somewhere and
then the interesting thing about the
target hack is that the whole system was
breached was it the way they got into it
was by exposing a vulnerability in the
vendor side of the system so the vendor
servers it was a one-off they could get
in and hack in through when people were
uploading their vendor documents and in
the in the kind of the awesome that
vendors would log into they got in
through there
we're able to describe the credit-card
information through here so by looking
at the whole system not just one piece
but the whole decision-making process
they found the vulnerabilities to hack
the system okay so what I'd like to
propose now is we kind of see that's a
great metaphor let's just try applying
it to a variety of things and we'll show
you theoretically how we can apply it to
something like food consumption and then
actually how we've applied it in some of
our and some of our consulting work so
food consumption we are it's a huge
problem thirty percent of of the u.s. is
now obese and it's and it's actually you
know more impactful when we look at
childhood obesity so this is the scary
chart that gets more scary as time goes
on where childhood obesity so so if we
want to pause for a second we're gonna
basically say how would we hack this
system and take this system down into a
cafeteria level so Brian Wansink is a
researcher at the University of Illinois
and he does a lot of if you're ever
interested in understanding more about
how to hack the food system mindless
eating in his latest book very nice but
let's just talk about how to hack a
cafeteria system so any ideas yeah we're
gonna get people to eat eat less or eat
healthier smaller please yes
oops so this is um this is a seminal one
basically we eat now there's some maple
with our eyes we have a small plate you
eat less yeah I would say labels in
general can can work depending on what
the label is so generically how we think
about information is that it's very nice
but if it's not surprising it doesn't
really change behavior so if you think
about calorie labels in New York very
nice
didn't make people eat healthier so
there's a few studies but plus or minus
a couple percentages right so it but
labels actually we'll come to this in a
second could be used in a different way
an hour to run this off if you ain't
like the government yeah so giving
somebody some kind of an opportunity
cost in their real life very nice
earlier yep very nice you could well
we'll get to another idea but yep yep so
this is actually kinda intuitive Trey's
have you eat healthier and the counter
and to notice is that you can't take a
salad plate if you have only one if you
don't have a tray and so in places where
you want to get salad you want to get
people to take an actual plate of salad
that's bigger you want them to have a
tray so they could take two plates yep
yep so you're talking about reducing
friction which is great so if you want
to say we want to reduce friction to two
healthy items and an add friction to two
non healthy ones there's also this
question of relativity of if you're
comparing a healthy versus a non healthy
thing is it easier to make the decision
and that probably depends on on the
person a little bit more as we think
about their mindset is they're going and
how set are they on a healthy versus a
non healthy beautiful great idea yes
thinking yes so having been the egg and
adding friction or adding adding a wait
time to things that are unhealthy and
and decreasing it for things that are
healthy yep sure I mean if people serve
you rather than you getting your own
food they can control how much you eat
yeah paternalism very nice so this is
though this is definitely one so serving
sizes and having a control just like the
small plates can you get it so that your
it's not that your eyes are eating for
you cool okay we'll go through some
things that Brian tested so so we have
this putting the brach layers and if you
said its put me the good things at the
front of the line so this is this is the
label idea of can we rename stuff but
actually make it seem more unhealthy so
let me say corn people maybe are more
attracted to creamy corn right so if
you're if you're able to basically give
sexy labels to things people will eat
them more so if you go to a restaurant
you think about actually it's just
chicken but they put all these labels
and why the chicken is amazing and it's
been tested for a menu that these types
of descriptive labels will increase the
perceived value and help us choose them
more frequently actually for our next
conference and started phenomics and
which is our annual conference we're
bringing a menu expert because they're
very good at helping understand the
relativity of decisions when people are
forced to make a choice hiding the ice
cream so this is exactly what it is you
close that you make it more opaque and
and what happens you actually have to
open it this is terrible right this
takes a lot of effort to open it but in
fact it actually works so one of the the
ideas that Danno is kind of prophesizes
to to folks he talks about and I don't
know if he's any met any refrigerator
appliance makers to get them to do this
but it would be why in the world do we
have our our fruit and veggie drawer in
the refrigerator to be a low so some of
times it's very low and it's opaque so
you can't see it so if things are gonna
go bad your you can't even see that it's
going to go bad and you have to make an
effort to open it how could we reduce
the friction of having the healthy stuff
in a refrigerator where we open the most
we see it the most be less and increase
the chances that we'll actually healthy
in a day-to-day basis okay
use of trays so this is the thing of
it's actually very nice to get people to
take a tray shrink the bowls so hiding
things
this isn't your paternalistic we're just
gonna make it like an Easter egg hunt
and hide things this is another kind of
counterintuitive one if you change how
the food looks and this could be
changing the bowl or adding lighting
will actually increase how much people
purchase healthy food offer a salad so
I'm just purely asking the question do
you want a salad so like less means you
have video when I started so I feel like
I should have video like maybe I should
have video right just putting the
question in your head of do you want a
salad will increase people taking it
instead of putting in the front of line
you can also block the cashier with the
salad bar some people have to move
around it in order to take things and
then this is the nice idea to have kind
of use the lines as a facilitator to
have people make better decisions so
imagine that you had one line for
unhealthy things in one line for healthy
things or you had people pay cash versus
credit card for the unhealthy thing so
just adding friction house people stop
and think and become a little bit more
rational than just reaching for the
cookie or reaching for the muffin yep
yeah so yep so so you know I go gonna do
this where they move around things a lot
and and so I think there is some kind of
a question of like am I being
manipulated which is really your
question of like how far can we go to
manipulate people and I kind of what I
would posit that we think is is we think
that just random somehow you know if the
cafeterias design it was purely random
that this is somehow not manipulation
either and in reality all just somebody
had to make the decision to put
something somewhere and so that decision
has been made for us either
intentionally to help us eat better and
if it's not intentionally then it's
still being made for us and making our
decisions that we're not even aware of
that it's being you know that our
decisions are being made by this random
victim algorithm right and so the
question is like do you believe in a
random algorithm or do you believe in
somebody actually designing designing
the system and obviously there are pros
and cons you say who's designing the
system matters a lot and that
case but in reality when you're talking
about you know eating healthy saving
money saving energy all these good
things you know they're we get more
liberties to design the system and be
the choice architect but yeah I mean if
you have people running around and like
digging for things and like there's no
point system to that then yeah there's
definitely a line and actually is your
building product so kind of the line is
usually legal right in deciding how far
you want to go even though it seems okay
you're still basically you have a lot of
rules and regulations that you can't do
okay so we're gonna go out with the next
thought exercise so have you guys you
guys go to the city and there's this
there's this cab company and it has
facial hair on the front of the cab so
so there's cab company and they cap
company and they they take riders from
one destination to the other and they're
busy and less busy times and less busy
times are let's call them Tuesday
mornings and more busy times our Friday
nights and drivers can make more money
on Friday nights because there's more
people on the roads but the problem is
that drivers also have lives too and
it's very difficult to convince them to
drive on Friday night when they also
would like to go out with their friends
but on Tuesday morning very easy to get
them to drive so we have this in
proportion we have a lot of people
wanting to drive on Tuesday not a lot of
people wanting to drive on Fridays but
more people wanting to take rides on
Fridays so we can't we got a question
says how would we convince people
drivers to drive more on Friday than on
Tuesday
what would us a so that is definitely
one answer for this we wanted to take
off the table money so money is
interesting for a couple reasons but
it's very expensive so if you think
about building a strategy based on money
you know we could pay everyone to do
everything maybe if you're Google you
can do this but most companies can't so
we don't want to build a long-term
strategy based on money if we don't have
to now there's definitely a variable we
could play with but if we don't have to
the other thing is money
more of and kind of kills the interest
interest ik interest equation and and it
basically takes away kind of any doing
it for the greater good aspect when
you're gonna start paying people its
imagine paying your kids to eat broccoli
right not so good because then they
won't they'll think they always need to
get paid to eat broccoli interesting yes
so basically beautiful women to driver
know there is something how do you make
it more attractive in general to have
people drive on Tuesdays oh so then they
they basically basically gonna then save
people pay a bar to have just make
Tuesday night the night in San Francisco
so kind of make it so it's an even
opportunity cost
this is very nice probably not as
practical since Friday always has that
allure of Saturday after it topped it
yeah so Taco Tuesday is doing some of
the work we would have to do a little
bit more I don't know what could be a
like well we'll go to other ideas for
this later yeah exactly so so this is
nice we are people opposed to a full
night and they think they have to drive
the full night or are they opposed to
just driving an hour to okay so they're
so basically calling on the ultra-stick
motivation so typically we think that
that that stuff is very nice but doesn't
work as well as something else if you
think about global warming right you
know the worst problem ever invented you
have you're basically trying to save the
world in a in a long you don't see the
counterfactual of the world actually
being saved so for this to work we'd
have to show them the counterfactual of
somebody getting in an accident from
drunk driving
well think about that one come back to
it yeah exactly so yeah so this is so-so
we understood that people actually want
fun could we play to that and make it
make it easier for them to have fun so
mutual destruction if I'm not having fun
no one's having fun I like it so this is
it I just don't want to be your friend
if you become a lyft driver then anyone
else so this is how we approach the
problem basically said okay let's look
at how people are making the decision to
drive and when to drive and then we're
gonna lay out the whole process of how
they make this decision and we'll figure
out when we can intervene kind of like
this hacker mental mentality right we
figure out how is the decision being
made and then where can we insert
ourselves and so what we have is drivers
activate their account they set up the
preferences for the number of hours that
they work they sign up once a week on
Wednesday to work the next week they get
notified of their hours in which they
actually have their hours confirmed they
drive and then they get notified for how
much they they make while they drive and
then if they want they can pick up hours
intermittently so with this flow well we
didn't say how where are people making
the decision to set their hours anyone
Wednesday yep and where are they
learning about how much money they could
make on a Friday night over a Tuesday
night not Wednesday yep two days after
they drive so then now this is kind of
interesting right so we basically say we
want to convince drivers that they
should drive on a different days but
we're telling them about the benefit of
doing it a completely different time
revolutionary but what if we told them
about the benefit of them driving at the
point they were making the decision so
we did basis bring the opportunity cost
of their decision on the scheduling
interface and we said when you're
picking your hours you now know it
Fridays you can make thirty five and on
Tuesdays you make fifteen oh my gosh and
then we told them it up for them and so
at the end they had a number of hours
and how much they would make versus how
much on average they could make if they
drove all Fridays we did this in
different conditions we said this is
very nice but
what if we actually showed them how much
game they could make by working more
Fridays so Fridays had that plus 15
right and so the average was Tuesday and
I was more money on Fridays so that's
also nice but we could also show that
much how much they're losing so on
Tuesdays we put a minus 15 and which
would work better right so basically
this is how we think about testing we
say okay we have a hypothesis we have a
theory of change that just showing
people the opportunity cost to the point
of decision is is is kind of our theory
here and we have different tests we have
different controls we think just showing
them is nice but we could probably do in
a gain and a loss and then we have a
control where there were no changes
interesting so you're saying get them
there like I still need 10 hours yeah
yeah I like this so this is actually how
people think so they don't think in how
much I make per hour they think in
totals of how much they're gonna make
per week so that would be a very nice
kind of giving them you said you wanted
to make $400 this weekend right now
you're at 300 you could work two Fridays
or five Tuesdays what do you want to do
and then have them sign up so get them
kind of at this like you know where
they're feeling emotional right yep very
nice that's great yeah so so this bowl
any ideas on which condition that we
tried worked because I mean I would
imagine that people dislike losing yes
you're correct here this is called
prospect theory and they do just like
losing more than they more than they
like gaming and so this is all the
conditions worked which is very nice and
then that one worked the most so
no showing them - so all yeah not all
the conditions but the conditions that
we tried to show them the opportunity
cost worked okay so now we're gonna do
another another fun what would we do to
reduce honking in India okay so I
haven't been a via but we have to
realize that there's honking in India
that happens a lot
yep so you have to let people know that
they're behind you you're behind that
yeah so there's this is actually what
the researchers they found that they
when they looked at people are they
honking out of danger all the time yeah
so so but when they look as it is it
necessary on a scale but wonder the
necessary of the measured is it
necessary that they honk and what they
realized what they realized that it was
much more habitual that these what I'm
doing this yep and but what you brought
up was a very nice point of we there's
one kind of thinking in behavioral
economics is let's just make a policy
which we usually think works the most
right if you just to make a lot up to
prohibit smoking people would smoke less
this is very nice and so here we are
trying to I bought the size on how to
get people to smoke less and in general
policy is one thing to go to now
obviously this just takes a really long
time for most things so in the product
world we got to get to hack that system
and say yes I understand the policy
would be much better but we are
fast-moving human beings and we would
like to get a change out sooner so in
general yes like a policy to have lanes
would probably you know given that you
get over the adoption hump what would be
the best cars you could like press three
times learn
beautiful okay we're gonna hold on to
that idea hold on to that nugget any
other ideas
what would that dude tell me more we
cause a drought or pressing the horn
will be so loud that it will start okay
yes so this startle effect
I like this we can call it oh my god so
in general we want to eat so the reason
honking is is not great is there's a
negative externality to it and that it
impacts people who aren't in the car
probably more than the people in the car
and so we're designing the system one of
the things to plus or minus is how much
of a negative externality are we
creating for other people around so if
we think that it's too much of a
negative externality that would be too
scary for us to implement because it
tragedy of the comments people are
honking louder but it's escalating
dangerous way like you can make the horn
a really embarrassing sound okay this is
great and if you have watched videos in
real sense Michael this is exactly what
they did so they basically they
basically had every time that you honked
it would honk back at you and you had to
turn it off so both of you guys were
right on of basically what this did is
it I'm going to press the button and I
know that I'm gonna have friction I'm
gonna have to think to turn it off and
so there's got people to stop and think
before they actually started honking so
when we think about a habit it's usually
done by just not thinking right and if
we want to stop a habit we want to
introduce some friction we want to make
people think before they actually
complete complete the task that is
usually routine yep driving like if
you're adding friction before you do
something that's like a mechanism
I need to like let you know there's
danger here at the other but it seems
kind of this is true so in India though
that with it this is the research that
they did prior to this is that they
figured out that people were honking out
of habit and that there's some
percentage of things that you actually
don't want to and it doesn't make you do
something before you honk right so it's
only after right but it lasts like
unless people are hopping out of habit
100% of the time there's like a yeah but
this doesn't prevent you from honking
right so there's nothing in between you
and hope what you're saying though is
that the that that you will no matter
what weather and like I realize doesn't
prevent you from honking what you're
saying is that it introduces friction
before you honk yep and if that happens
100% of the time but not 100 percent of
the time are you honking out of habit
like yeah I think you're onto something
of how much if we introduce if we didn't
reduce thinking before something and
their way to think too much and
something that we don't need to think in
that should be instinctual and the thing
with danger zones like this we think
actually our instinctual so we think
that if if you're going to be in a
dangerous situation that you would be
instinctive to do this and that we
actually just want to interfere and make
you think in times where you could
change that behavior but in general if
you're in a dangerous situation the
hypothesis was that you're not you're
not going to be stopping from honking
because you're thinking that that's
actually the instinct the security éxito
is that if you push the door and Stevens
here too long so you people don't want
to push that door kill money but other
people in the room but in the standard
cases that they can understand emergency
issues over those embarrassment so I can
still use that all yep yep good to know
Amy get the habit of punking twice
yeah maybe so the the net result of this
study was 60% reduction in honking
and you don't really know what would
happen if people were using this for a
long time maybe they were doing yep
so so this is a nice question just in
general about how behavioral economics
takes long term effects and and in
general they're you know an ideal world
we're actually studying much longer term
effects than we do so for eating or
smoking or any kind of behavior change
we need to really study a longitudinal
and and there's this kind of first use
and elongated use that people think of
so you're right on I think with this
this is something where you're just
adding friction and again if you can get
them over the habit hump actually doing
it all the time then the long-term
effects hopefully that you don't need to
to keep doing the honking this is
obviously social coordination effort
right if everyone's still honking and
then you're the only one who's changed
it's a different story but the theory of
the case is that for some behaviors if
you can create a new habit that you
don't need the negative reinforcement to
go on forever
other other thoughts so this is as I was
talking about kind of how we lay out the
process this is what we did for a
insurance company in South Africa where
we basically said they want people to go
to the gym and we laid out we went to
the gym we went through their whole
process you know they have discounts at
supermarkets they have fitness
assessments they get their glucose
tested they want people to go to the gym
and so co-worker and I went through the
whole process and then laid out for one
specific behavior one of the big pieces
that we want people to do where is that
vulnerability and one of the barriers to
doing this action and then we apply
behavioral economics to these barriers
and so it's become kind of a very nice
understanding the full system looking at
the details with a curiosity for human
behavior and when we have the tools of
the user psychology we can kind of work
backwards and solve so again
kind of you know it's my big hypothesis
and the theory here is that the
principles of human decision-making are
actually the principles of product
design and so is where product designers
you know we're not just looking at ants
asking users questions but we're looking
at more of the theory of how they
respond to big decisions in front of
them and that we can narrow it down into
understanding the environment is
important that small details matter and
and friction is a big determinant and
many times we get this wrong right we
pay attention to the things that don't
matter we use our gut instinct and we
hold on to things a bit too long so I'll
leave you guys with some good and bad
news so the the bad news is that over
the last 100 years ago
10% of our mortality was determined by
human decision making any guesses for
what
how much is determined by now so how
much do we affect our own death
decisions that humans make affect human
death a little bit higher right now our
40% of dusts are impacted by human
decision-making and this means you know
look this is all the cancers this is
diabetes smoking that we actually
control and this is good there's
obviously terrible news and this is good
news for people who are willing and
ready to create products and solutions
that can help solve them so the world is
not getting any easier you know kind of
the Danny early always says the Dunkin
Donuts v-2 2.0 is going to be more
unhealthy and less good for us than the
first one and so we have to figure out
mechanisms and products and solutions to
help kind of curve this 40% but the
people in this room and the people that
were friends with are the people to do
this right given the fact that the
environment can influence decision
making this is a huge win for product
people right because it means we can
design the environment we can help
people who have intentions meet their
actions and super empowering for all of
us
and that is all that I've got do we have
questions or how do you want to great
crickets thank you guys yep how change
because sometimes you know people say
when you make the decision usually like
guys supposed to be more rational but
like you can see a lot of examples like
when people buy iPhone and you ask
whether they choose the white color or
the black color the women usually give
you answer like oh I just don't like the
white color or they don't think like why
they really like it but when you see the
casing for the guys they go to the Apple
store and they have the ho plan but like
for the last minute they change their
their plan so I am NOT saying like oh
man I'm more rational than the women but
like do they do you guys have a research
like to show whether the gender play a
different role like in how they make the
decision like you know the rationale
they use different way to show well yeah
so to answers your questions it's a nice
what about individual differences in
general and how the field looks and
individual differences and in reality
there hasn't been too many findings
about individual differences like this
person is so much you know if this
person pays attention to social proof
and this person pays attention to loss
aversion that's just who I am and that
is who I will be forever instead the
field looks at it like a mindset so in
in some instances you have the mindset
let's let's just do search and browse
which we were talking about at lunch and
some in some instances you're in the
mindset of search in some instances
you're in the mindset of browse in the
search world you're Morris except to
social proof sorry in the browser world
you're more willing to accept social
norms and in the search world you're not
and so it's really not you know but in
another world when I'm searching for you
know let's say shoes cuz I have no idea
how to buy shoes
I did you know I didn't before I was
very successful to social norms and now
I'm not it's acceptable to social norms
and so it's really the mindset that
we're going into a problem with so then
the question becomes do women and men
have different mindsets and I think we
have different mindsets and different
types of products so so we may be more a
keen to or this the in the culture that
we live in there may be some times where
we have different mindsets but the
question really is when you're think
about designing the product what is your
users mindset and usually it's not
determined by gender or age or race or
culture or even the second thing is that
our our environment determines a lot of
power social were socially brought up so
this researcher went to basically said
women seem to react negatively to
competition versus men and this has kind
of been proven across Western society
that you've had a Craigslist ad and you
have people applying to make it more or
less competitive to get more men if it's
more competitive and less women which is
very interesting if you think about you
know the Sheryl Sandberg kind of
movement is actually women don't respond
as well to competition and the question
was is this something inherent to women
or is it something that kind of society
has brought us up so what he did is gone
I don't forget what the Society was but
in Africa there was this group which
actually had the roles flipped so the
women were the patriarchs and women were
the people who led the society they were
the ones who kind of made all the
decisions and he played the same kind of
a game where he played with women in the
u.s. he played that with women in this
culture and it turns out that they were
more competitive than men so the
hypothesis there is that we don't a we
don't really know us this is you know
one society versus all of the Western
you guys were not really sure but but
the theory is that people it's a mindset
and it's how our culture has grown up
that it's not an inherent difference in
us that would kind of make us act
differently if you think about the
differences you know of humans we talked
about fraternal twins being different
but like literally the differences
between humans just aren't that much if
you think about that as an aggregate
world though they were actually quite
similar yep
was how much does a person's habits
print you that and number two years was
some strong emotions that you could
leverage to to make people change that
behavior for someone for smoking that's
also one thing you think yeah so emotion
in general is one of the most powerful
forces of why we do the things we do so
we we high level this to like yes
emotions and no emotions where you have
something that could bring you fear and
then you're pulled away from it and you
don't want to do it or is something that
could get you excited and you want to do
it so getting you know somebody these
dating sites get you very emotionally
aroused with pictures of nice-looking
people and and gets you attracted to
going there versus something like a
audit system that's gonna get you fear
of losing your money
so in general emotions actually kind of
drive a lot of our behavior and it
manipulating people's emotional state at
the point of decision is a big big
tactic for how how we think about
behavior change and it's going to be
different with each kind of product that
we're talking about so there's no like
one like you should use fear here you
know fear is is very motivating but as a
long-term negative effects when you're
thinking about managing your money you
don't really want to lose it and we get
you to act initially but but what do you
think about long term so there's no
unfortunately most of their of economics
is never carbon copy here's a framework
here's what you do and just it's mostly
understanding the environment and this
kind of hacking way and and figure out
how to apply it
did I miss a question you had another
one I was wondering also what's the role
of habits
yeah habits are something interesting
because we you know this is kind of
habit like thing where product people
really want to figure out how to make
their prop their behavior a habit and we
really want to think deeply about that
like how much do we need to be in a
users live life that we're not
interfering like in general I don't want
to log into my accounting system every
day this is just not want to be a habit
and yet product teams are thinking I
need to increase engagement on each
increase engagement and in reality how
much actually has to be a habit and I
proposed not too much right so good
behaviors even same
money if you default us like we don't
have to think about how much money we're
saving everyday you know they're little
decisions but but again we really want
to think carefully about why we won't
have it so we'll start there and then in
general habits are something where you
want to think about when it fits in the
users time of the day so I don't think
we talk we talk a lot about triggers in
the world of of habits I'm kind of high
on the horse of figuring out when you
can hack my day is it before I get on
the train is it after I you know get off
is it right before I go to bed you know
brushing our teeth is like the biggest
universal habit that we have in there to
set times a day that we do it you know
there's some reward substitution with a
with a toothpaste going on but but in
general we have it time to do it and we
have a place and there's some social
coordination to it so I'm not a huge
proponent of having habit saying we
should just form habits with every
product that we're doing this is a good
idea but we can be very thoughtful about
it and it's more about figuring out when
during your day we can hack your life I
just stuck to him right before this so
yeah so basically if you're talking
about this what I want to be in where I
am everyone wants to be on top of the
news on top of their email on top of the
information in their lives and so what
we should be going to do is is create a
lot of design interventions that allow
them to achieve and yet there is a
collective drink everyone is doing this
everyone is less effective where I
despite my my intention unless I was
trying to do yep there are too many to
be this one is there some you know do
you just read that as a collective
system where we now need to rehab across
all of these different products yeah I
think I people are it is a scary world
we're going into right so everyone's
kind of vying for your attention and
it's try someone say they've put you
know like Ted like all these Harvard
grad
to make you login that Facebook more
high are we supposed to fight against
this and it's true it's like it's very
very difficult so I think there's
different approaches that you can take
one is kind of a policy right we're
going to say you know in general apps
can only have X amount of notifications
they can only trigger you so much they
can get you these times but they can't
catch you at these times and that
there's that's like the policy way oh I
want to know immediately yeah so so some
of this is a collective consciousness of
that this is not good for us and then
the policy would have to come from that
so I'm not a big believer in policy
being the fastest way but you can
imagine web standards how web standards
forms is that there was the uniform way
of doing something and became you know
the UI the UI is within mobile apps were
just kind of grabbing direct
drag-and-drop then and people understood
the framework of how to act and behave
so one approach would be understanding
is there always an offsetting to apps
right where we we basically add in more
features that let the user either
default themselves into not having it
not having it go off at certain times or
shutting it on silent at certain times
or only letting certain things through
and so there's there's the mechanisms of
defaults that's missing from this system
right now like they're like literally
we're just not able to turn off or say
what we want and if we can't default
ourselves into a better state then apps
don't have just going to keep coming so
if we can't say no you can't do that
then the user has to have some control
over that and then there's this you know
just in general kind of how do we
prioritize our time and I don't think
we're there yet where we understand that
this is a problem so there's some social
coordination there around as well to get
this to be a problem and so it's now
looked upon you know that you answer
your email quickly it's like a very good
thing so if you can create a social norm
even within a small company that this is
a bad thing you could you could probably
help with how people go about their day
now we can't change the whole world but
these kind of team related social norms
are very powerful to get people not to
to reward behavior like responding to an
email right away
not only weird here like you insist that
maybe they saw I'm looking as much but
also potentially a loser being guided
toward behaviors that they may not have
chosen to do otherwise you know imagine
that you are not the good news those
would be the people who are doing the
shitty things have learned this long ago
so we're preaching really to the number
of the people who are trying to change
big behavior because the magazine stands
BuzzFeed they've got it right like it's
the nonprofit's like I talked to this
gal who was running learn up and she's
trying to get people to like from apply
to to job so low-income people to apply
to jobs at like staples and Walgreens
right and I'm like hey Alexis we just
need to add a deadline so that people
have a time to respond because if you're
out a deadline we've done a test before
it increases response rates by 10x she's
like there is no way I could I could
take that service away from people
because that's just we want to give the
service of of having them being able to
apply whatever so the the the mindset
really has to change for people who are
trying to do good things because because
they're not they're going uphill right
against human behavior and in reality we
react very well to deadlines right their
self control mechanisms for us and so
but but the mindset when we're trying to
do these kind of nice behavior change
you talk to a non-profit they're just
clueless about some of this so I agree
it's not it's something where if you say
you know in reality we talk to Zynga
folks and they understand this you know
we're not we're not teaching them a ton
of thing although we think we can teach
them how to get more enjoyment from
games and design the experience better
so that people are happier if they're
wasting this amount of time regardless I
mean nobody but you think about
designing an experience like this and
you think how would you do it so people
are better off and actually we could do
it so people are better off right this
is not their motivation yeah if I'm
talking a little bit more about the
browser versus the search world they're
like you know you complain to social
norms ours is not compliant resolution
homes yeah as it applies to product
detection so if you think about
uncertainty so if I were to hand you a
coupon I were to either hand it to you
when you're at the checkout of a store
or if I were to hand it to you before
you
got a right because you were getting out
of the car which would you be more
successful - exactly this is what social
proof is to browse and search is
basically you think about someone
certainty in what they're gonna purchase
or certainty in their decisions and
social proof works best in uncertain
situations when we don't actually know
what we want or we don't know the right
way to behave so if you if you basically
you're certain you're browsing for
something you don't really know if
somebody says you know 80% of people
have bought this you're like thank you
very much this will go into my decision
framework versus if you say I actually
really want this telling me the 80% of
people already bought something else
much harder to convince me out of it but
it's not who I am it's a mindset of how
I'm approaching my product decision or
one more joke if this is administrated
after class the website redirect is down
right so I guess I was gonna ask
something sort of related
so obviously you guys are talking about
a positive behavior change and clearly
this companies out there that are trying
to induce negative behavior change or
itself certain behavior change for them
yep so as individuals though what would
you say are clues that you could look
out for - like as you start falling into
the funnel of being manipulated
interesting so so I think you want to
figure out if you're bridging the
attention action gap so does the user
have an intention to do something and
are you helping them then complete this
action so for instance you think about
doing you know diabetes you you could
tell you know doctors or people who you
know they're saying I I think you need
to exercise this much and I think you
need to eat this much and I think you
need to take this amount of insulin and
this is very paternalistic of them to
tell us this because in reality what
should happen is they should take me
personally and
individual and say you personally given
all of your stats need to do something
or they should say Kristen just figure
it out you know we you know you should
be able to say how much of to eat and
how much you have to diet and how much
you have to exercise when in reality
these things are very very difficult for
an individual to figure out themselves
it is very difficult for a doctor to
just prescribe me
you know me personally a recommendation
on this and so we end up doing is it's
very the system is very noisy difficult
for me to figure it out
difficult to even give me a personal
recommendation in this case we're better
just giving a recommendation to a group
of people who are in their mid-20s and
what they should do and you think about
that kind of thing you're saying you
know yeah I'm being paternalistic and
I'm telling everyone one thing that I
think they should do but in reality
you're making a decision on my life much
much easier because there's no way that
I could figure it out by myself and
there's no way that you personally as a
doctor could give me one prescription so
so I think you want you really wanna
think intention action is it going to be
harder for the user to figure it out so
a lot of times we think we're you know
we're data engineers you have these data
engineers at Google saying you know I
could they can't they just figure it out
it's like well if you can't figure it
out how do they figure it out
and so it you know giving people choices
sometimes to detriment is is worse
thought makes them worse off too many
choices in 401k people don't choose to
have a retirement this is terrible right
and then it was terrible that we need
one joke I can't live that it's terrible
you